bring in uh gary stevenson who used to
be a city trader now works as an
equality campaigner gary good to have
you with us this evening
um let's begin then briefly with your
thoughts in a nutshell really as to
what was said with regards to housing
and
whether or not actually you feel this
could do perhaps more harm than good
yeah so the chances come in uh just as
you did last year with
bearing gifts for home buyers and home
owners
um the stamp duty holiday has been
extended
also i think what could be more
important is he's trying to push these
mortgages by the government guaranteeing
some losses from banks
um now a lot of people will be pleased
to see this
especially homeowners my big concern is
that just as we saw last year in the
middle of a massive crisis and recession
house prices shot up the record highest
this could really be pouring more flames
on the fire of the house price crisis
um you know for some people if you're
for example a family like rishi sunak
his dad's a billionaire
you can ask his dad for a five percent
deposit but for a lot of ordinary people
who don't have that money thing to have
they're gonna have to sit on the
sidelines and possibly watch house
prices rise
much faster than their savings do here
so really this is gonna split the house
from the have
not do you have the money for the
deposit now or do you have to sit by and
watch those prices go up
if the government had said right we're
going to scrap stamp duty
and we're going to make it harder for
you to get a mortgage we're going to
keep it at 10 20
deposits what would you have said to
that
to be honest somebody said if the
government wants to fix house price
prices
it should stop trying to push house
prices up and start looking at wages
because really the problem here is
people are not earning enough money
to buy these houses wages have done
nothing what are the wages done in the
last 15 years
in that time london house prices have
more than doubled really i think
the government is looking the wrong
places because it's wages for ordinary
working families without the problem and
deeper than that i think there's a
problem with inequality here because as
you've seen the riches get richer and
richer
they've been using that money to push
house prices up but not driving the
economy which is where working people's
wages come from
so i think the government should look
beyond these simple measures towards the
problems with inequality in our society
let's just touch on some of the the
measures when it comes to universal
credit there was a confirmation today
that the
20 pound uplift 20 pound week uplift
will continue for some time however it
was not made permanent as some people
have called for
your thoughts on that is that kind of
good news in the interim but actually
we're still not really solving the
problem here of being able to improve
people's quality of life
yeah there's no doubt as good as the
interim because obviously there are a
number of people especially the millions
of people who've received
no support during this crisis because
they've fallen through the gaps of the
government support schemes
for them i mean 20 pounds a week might
not seem like a lot to some people
but for a lot of people it's been
lifeline so of course it's absolutely
essential
that the government extended it but i
think especially when you look at what's
happened in the last years of stock
markets and
the wealthiest people have been making
huge amounts of money
really a humane society should be
looking at supporting also the people
who suffered in this crisis because
there's a lot of people
who are paying for this and that need to
be dealt with
and just uh on um renters as well uh you
know
a suggestion really that actually things
like the temporary
ban on evictions again good news but
actually
did you see anything in today's budget
which gave you hope that actually life
would
become easier for those perhaps renting
privately
i mean this is my concern you know the
government has been forced to do a lot
of support for people that
it wouldn't normally support it hasn't
really been on the side of private
renters that much
since it's been in power it's been
forced to provide multiple and and it's
good that it has done that
but my concern is they're only really
doing as much as they have been forced
to do
and when we come out of this just as
we've seen they've been
using policies which are going to push
house prices up which are going to help
the richest in our society
when we come out of this they're giving
every sign that they're going to go back
to supporting
the people who fund the conservative
party and people like richard
family who are very very wealthy okay uh
gary thank you gary stevenson there
former city trader now working as an
inequality campaigner sharing his
thoughts his reaction then to
some parts of the budget